ايضا موضوع القمح سلت قمح العالم وامه
الغذائي لم يكن في ماء من خلال العام 2022
جر الحرب فمعن دلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا في
فبراير الماضي اغلقت الموانئ وتوقفت حركته
تصدير الحبوب من اوكرانيا ودفع ذلك اسعار
الغذاء في العالم الى مستويات قياسيه في
روسيا تعد اكبر مصدر للقمح في العالم
واوكرانيا خامس اكبر مصدر حصه كبيره من
السوق في شهر مارس الماضي بعد بدء الحرب
باسابيع حذرت منظمه اليونيسيف من سقوط
اليمن في ازمه جوعا كارثيه
بعدها اتسع دائره التحذير وهذه المره من
الامم المتحده التي دعت لاتخاذ اجراءات
الانسانيه عاجله في 20 بؤره جو ابرزها
اثيوبيا وجنوب السودان واليمن والصومال
وافغانستان وسيرلانكا ودول غرب افريقيا
الساحليه واوكرانيا ولبنان في يوليو تنفذ
العالم السعداء بتوقيع روسيا واوكرانيا
اتفاقيه برعايه الامم المتحده وتركيا في
اسطنبول تتيح العوده الى تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه هدد الظروف الحرب الاتفاق وعلق
تنفيذه في اواخر شهر قبل التوافق على
اعاده تفعيل اليه التصدير لكن بشكل عام لم
ينتهي الخوف من بقاء العالم على سفير
الجوع بعد تجربه مباشره هددت امنه الغذائي
بشكل اسرع مما كنا نتخيل
[موسيقى]